>> WE HAVEARY SLEP
WE SEP, BUT ANOUSLL CO
WILL BLE  WILL BE AFTER THE WAR
AFTER THE VI
TRY AS WE
NEED.
>>EO
ESVOLODYMYKYY,R COMEDIAN
POLITICAL NOVICE.HEUNTRY  FOR S.
WE LOOK AT HIS P
>> Reporte O GD ASON WHY ANYONE
IN THE POPULAR UKRAINIAN T
OTR UNLIKELY
A TEACHER SULYVAD TO
E HIGHEST OFFICE AFTER
GOES VIRAL.T
IN REAL LIFE, HIS POLITICAL
PAY HOW
AS
ZELENSKYY'S SHZ CARE
COMEDY AND LIGHT ENTERTAINMENT,
HOM TO THEELEASE.
PERILOUS MOMENFOS
IS IFAHE
LEADE THINK I SAY.AND
HE'S A MAN OF EXTRAOARILITIES.AY
D THROUGH
EXAMPLE HIS VIDEOS FROM THE STR
KYIV ARECHED YWRE, DETERMINED,
WORLD  D.
AND HE HASVID THE
OF THE WAR
TOUTF KYIV WITH THE
AMMUNITION, NOT A RIDE. A YSU A
E IS HAS
STRENGTHENED P
WITHS T OFTA AGGIOeporter: HE C
OUTCOME, YOUELIEVE ODOHE IS NOAL
YMBOL OF
AGAINSELMINGN ANLU TEIENN'SCHANW
THE PERSONALKS HARDSHIPS
ENDURING?
PRESIDENT OINE.
IT THAPECIAL C.UKRAINE IS ICONIW
COY.
UKRAINE IS THEEART OF EUROPE. R
HIS
HEAT ACROSIDTE019, CLEAR T
EXP STATESMAN.
FOR HIM.T, HE'VE